hallo mein name ist luca und viele sagen
mir ich soll behinderte spiegel spielen
ab das mache ich jetzt heute davor dass
chkl wir sind hier gerade in einer welt
drin und auch kummer während tutorial da
oben presste die kameraperspektive
verstößen ist dieses tutorial jetzt
komplett egal da oben ich mache drei
minuten und ich glaube ich habe das
spiel langsam verstanden das spiel ist
quasi wie minecraft nur anders danke
luca das uns immer so toll die spieler
erklärt wir können uns die quasi
irgendwas bauen und das was ich hier
gerade kreiert habe ist ein bereich wenn
wir in dem lebendig aus der bereich ist
welche habe ich im inventories
verschiedene sachen die ich mir in die
hautpartien kann wie beispielsweise eine
pferde schnauze und wenn ich jetzt
beispiel dass man blog nehme einfach mal
linksklick drücke dann mache ich hier
also ein bereich in dem ich irgendetwas
machen kann das heißt wir drücken sich
auf das herz fange an irgendwas zu bauen
und das ist dann quasi eine kreatur die
nachher lebt das ganze spiel ist noch in
der beta
das merkt man tatsächlich auch jetzt
hier über mein gott ich dachte schon ich
hab schilder kaputt gemacht ich weiß gar
nicht wie ich das richtig bauen soll und
jetzt schmeiße ich auch noch hemberger
da drauf das geht bei mir einfach
überhaupt nicht gefragt mich bitte nicht
was das hier später werden soll okay
okay ich habe hier jetzt einfach mal
noch
augen was sind denn das für augen dann
kriegt er halt hier vorne dran und dann
kriegt er da noch ein auge hin und jetzt
wow sieht toll aus die pferde schnauze
kommt dahin denn genau so was darf bei
so einer kreatur natürlich auch nicht
fehlen
haare ja wenn ich nur aus diesem bereich
raus hier ist meine kreatur am leben
ich bin begeistert will bleibt ihr du
kannst nicht einfach das machen was du
grad machst wels ecken slater
lass mich los
hat film ich gegessen ich bin irgendwie
viel drin zilks die ganze bibel aus oder
säcke den staat jetzt einmal neue spiele
sind jetzt in einer aber wir wären ja
nicht luca also wir sind ähnlich luca
ich bin so kann ein wo läufst du hin wie
hunden kommen die füße dran da haben wir
zwei füße direkt nebeneinander
oh mein gott was macht sie doch
gefälligst euch das ist jetzt auch
schwer ihn zu treffen weil er sich
einfach die ganze dem kreis bewegt man
ich kann irgendwie nichts mehr an die
figur anbringen die läuft komplett aus
dem ruder wir lassen die figuren einfach
mal so und mal schauen ob sie
was mache ich hier süßen es ist das
beste wäre nur mit mir mit kommst ich
weiß noch nicht was sie da oben versucht
zu machen so siehst du bleibst genau
hier
ok dann kann ich jetzt nämlich schön
eine tolle andere figur bauen susan ist
echt lieb die bleibt halt wirklich genau
da stehen oder sie will raus gehen und
weiß nicht wie ich habe gerade irgendwie
hier sondern eingefunden
ich weiß nicht ob ich damit jetzt
einfach eine neue figur was habe ich
getan
kann ich damit die ganze zeit hier neue
figuren theoretisch die figur ist fertig
und ich nenne sie die missgeburt sie
kann wenigstens gut tanzen als ich
jemals fragt während ihr aussehen würde
dass ich es schaffen würde so was macht
denn süßen wein laufe nicht weg gelaufen
und jetzt macht sie denn wieder voller
noch gechillt weiß nicht was mit der los
ist und wenn ihr euch fragt was susan
die ganze folge lang macht versucht noch
immer rauskommt ok freunde ich habe
angst vor dieser kreatur
ich fliege hier nun raus um euch die
kreatur zu zeigen die ich gerade
erstellt habe aber bitte lasst mich
nicht die neue kreatur ist
doch wie mother backing ein octopus
lobby du hast mich nicht aufwecken
slater lobby hat mich aufgegessen meine
welt ist total behindert süßen versucht
die ganze zeit aus diesem ding raus zu
kommen und boogie woogie attackiert
jetzt nicht wirklich süßen oder ich will
einfach die ich mal meinen freunden
vorstellen aber du drehst dich die ganze
zeit zu mir schau mal wenig hinten
gefunden
vielleicht ein freund guck mal ich hab
viel warten wir sind ganz normale
freunde ich hab dich kreiert ich bin
dein herrscher ich bin dann schafft ihr
es tut mir leid aber ich glaube es macht
keinen sinn phil hat einfach viel zu
viel angst vor mir viel wir sind ganz
lieb wir wollen nur ganz kurz hallo
sagen ich habe mir neue figur kreiert
und ich glaube die hatte ich echt lieb
hirschau die nokia macht liebe oder so
das macht keinen sinn mehr ich kann
nicht sehen durch deine haare wenn euch
das video gefallen hat dann zeigt sie
mit einer bewertung wollte den zweiten
teil der kmk